alors en ce lendemain d'élections en
voyant ce qui attend le nouveau
gouvernement de justin trudeau et les
chefs des autres partis
je me disais ils sont avec nous ce soir
sur ce plateau grand plaisir que
j'accueille daniel tâche à chelles
bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va prendre un moment quand même
pour revenir sur ce qui s'est passé hier
soir daniel vous disais qu'est ce qui
s'est passé hier soir plus frappés parce
qu'évidemment jeudi dernier on était ici
ensemble on parlait d'une possibilité
d'un gouvernement libéral minoritaire
je crois qu a pas beaucoup de gens qui
avaient envisagé un gouvernement
majoritaire en tout cas avec moi une
majorité comme celle là alors
tasha je commence avec vous qu'est ce
qui vous a plus rapide dans ce qui s'est
passé hier soir qu'on voit le plus
c'était en ontario voir la couronne de
toronto et toronto dépeint complètement
en rouge de ma circonscription de whitby
ou l'ancien ministre flaherty feu
monsieur flaherty était pendant huit ans
chateaufort conservateurs non libérale
maintenant jusqu à mississauga brampton
tous les autres comtés et aussi dans le
nord nous manque est tous les comptes et
effectivement on peut parler de la
voiture du vote ethnique ou des
communautés ethniques mais aussi du
centre toronto les aider aussi à tomber
ça c'était pour moi quelque chose de
jamais jack est un oui absolument tout
rouge pour uche manière écoutez moi ce
qui m'a frappé qui m'a frappé c'est que
l'histoire se répétait hier quand les
canadiens sont années le gouvernement et
qu'ils en ont assez
il répudie et de façon cavalière et de
façon catégorique l'avait fait avec les
libéraux pierre trudeau à 84 des
conservateurs de mots l'honneur 93 et
hier soir il était clair qu'ils en
avaient assez de stephen hart le coach
parti conservateur qui se maintient qui
reste un effort très important au canada
mais de stephen rapp sans référendum sur
lui et ils ont foutu à la porte et rend
ce contexte comme celui-là le gagnant
c'est celui qui se positionnent de mieux
qui fait la meilleure campagne
thomas mulcair aurait dû gagner parce
que c'est lui qui a fait tout le travail
de sape contre ainsi rappelé au cours
des dernières années mais c'est juste un
de nos carrières
parce qu'il a fait la meilleure campagne
parce qu'il a le physique de l'emploi
et parce qu'il représentait vraiment le
changement que vous cherchez des
canadiens michel a écouté ce qui m'a
frappé moi c'est vraiment l'ampleur de
l'effondrement du npd au québec et en
corollaire la facilité avec laquelle le
vote francophone s'est déplacé vers les
libéraux oui on voulait se débarrasser
de monsieur harper encore qu'au québec
monsieur harper a augmenté sa
représentation
mais c'est surtout de voir des gens dont
un bon nombre de souverainistes
j'imagine se tourner vers trudeau un
trudeau avec tout ce que ça rappelle de
mauvais souvenirs
je sais pas exactement ce que ça veut
signifie pour l'avenir mais il ya
certainement un tournant
c'est comme si on avait accepté de faire
abstraction de toutes les villes ni le
qu'on pouvait reprocher aux libéraux
dans le passé et est de jouer le jeu a
tout tenté de rejouer le jeu politique
canadien alors ça pourrait être un
tournant très vrai que beaucoup de gens
et on l'a entendue dans ce cas les gens
dès aujourd'hui j'en voulais que
monsieur rein peut s'en aille et donc
c'était ça c'était la mémé dans un
compte dans un contexte où il y aurait
une fébrilité mettons souverainiste au
québec sa tournée vers monsieur trudeau
sarr a peut-être été moins facile que ça
pour ajouter à ce que michel dit ce qui
était annoncé qu'au québec où
l'opposition au niqab est la plus forte
et que ça fait très mal
aa thomas mulcair sa cristalliser
l'opinion sont en angleterre on a bâti
pour justin trudeau qui loin qu'un
acteur qui avaient plus de chances de
rester
c'était cette raison là le reste vient
de regarder le québec et le reste du
canada et à la fin de la journée ils ont
tous les deux dit il faut choisir un
champion et ça va être monsieur trudeau
alors on va se tourner un peu vers
l'avenir qu'est ce que ça veut dire ce
gouvernement
justin trudeau qu'est ce que ça change
au niveau des relations
fédérales-provinciales parce que là il
ya vraiment un changement de ton le vue
mais pas seulement il ses relations avec
la presse et relations avec le reste du
monde
mais avec les provinces aussi parce que
ça change
il y en avait pas de relations fédérales
provinciales au cours des dix dernières
années monsieur rares pu enfin se pose
ce n'était pas dans son adn
il ya mais pas ça il faut dire à la
défense stephen harper c'est très
important c'est que il a toujours été
très respectueux de juridiction
provinciale n'est jamais venu avec ses
gros sabots fram les libéraux l'ont déjà
fait dans le passé dans les champs de
compétence des provinces
c'est rue de réunir des provinces il a
toi gros problèmes sur la table il va
faire un tour de table sur le sénat pour
réaliser qui a rien à faire nord fait
dépouillant fera pas en entendre parler
probablement catégorie non plus que ce
qu'il fait avec le sénat cette patate
chaude
deuxièmement effet dépouilleurs l'aldi
ce matin deux dossiers prioritaires très
important qui implique de grosses
dépenses la péréquation qu'il faut
revoir
premier musée saskatchewan va jusqu'à
dire que c'est trop généreux que le
québec en soit au d'argent entre autres
le financement des programmes de santé
ce sont deux très gros dossier des
négociations extrêmement difficiles à
venir
et là on va voir jusqu'à quel point la
volonté de monsieur trudeau de garder
des bonnes relations étaient progresser
sur l'idée qu'il est capable le dossier
de l'énergie qui est très importante et
c'est la touche de pays de l'est à
l'ouest et les positions là dedans ce
n'est pas clair comment monsieur trudeau
valérie absolument et c'est pour lui je
pense on passe d'une situation
bilatérales ou monsieur traiter avec les
provinces
un situation multilatérale les réunir en
réunion on sait ce que ça fait on
demande l argent alors c'est ça que
monsieur trudeau matérialiser très
rapidement le plus que tu réunis depuis
ce que je demande que tu as alors oui la
volonté est là mais je pense que ça va
être il va avoir à gérer cette situation
où les gens me pose toujours la même
question où est mon argent michel qu'est
ce que ça change pour le québec si les
couleurs les relations avec les copains
les relations vont voir avec monsieur
couillard en étant si t'as pas très
mauvais avec monsieur un peu il
s'entendait plutôt bien avec monsieur
trudeau je pense que à tout cas en
partance havre est extrêmement bon il va
y avoir une meilleure représentation du
québec au gouvernement central ça me
paraît évident avec les conservateurs en
quantité qu'en qualité
maintenant il faut le dire maintenant il
faut il faut quand même pas imaginer
qu'on retourne au french power
regardons par exemple regarder en 1980
dans le gouvernement de ce trio avait
fait élire plus de la moitié de ses
députés au québec
là c'est à peine le quart alors on n'est
pas dans la même proportion faut pas
s'attendre à revenir une situation comme
celle-là et d'autre part c'est pas parce
que on est à la table qui on est
québécois que
ça fait on fait nécessairement ce qu'on
veut pourquoi québec ou avec le québec
souvenez vous de rapatriement de la
constitution
à 90 il y avait soixante quatorze
députés sur 75 qui avait été élu au
québec
ça n'a pas empêché le gouvernement
trudeau de faire ce qu'ils voulaient
même si le gouvernement du québec et
l'opposition officielle à québec
cet acompte de rapatriement alors c'est
pas une garantie non mais quand même le
bloc ne peux pas dire maintenant que
québec n'est pas représenté au sein du
gouvernement stauffer pour moi c'est
l'impact sur le bloc va être très sévère
parce qu'ils doivent se dire mais c'est
quoi leur but c'est quoi l'objectif
chercher aussi comment intégrer monsieur
duceppe dans le décor quand il n'est pas
qu'il n'y a pas de siège et ça c'était
une autre chose qui m'a frappé un
circuit qui me succède venir c'est très
important se respecte monsieur duceppe
d'après vous est-ce qu'il peut rester
hors jeu voit mal comment il va rester
leurs bombes a décidé de réfléchir un
peu plus vite parce que j'imagine que
réfléchi mais je pense que honnêtement
je m'attends ce que monsieur seul s'en
aille
non surtout ceux ci avaient été élus
dans dernier sainte-marie bon je pense
que monsieur canaris son manga mais là à
nettement ça fait beaucoup là
vale pour quelqu'un qui a quand même sa
fierté et il faut bien voir que le bloc
encore perdu des plumes la cette
élection si c'est pas parce qu'ils aient
augmenté son nombre de députés que ça
masque le fait qu'il ya il est tombé
maintenant sous la barre des 20% là
c'est jamais arrivé depuis la création
du bloc alors ça va pas bien le portable
parlons du parc des autres parties du
parti conservateur du npd qu'est ce qui
s'en vient
comment est ce que vous voyez cette
course qui s'annonce le parti
conservateur de l écouter à suivre un
peu a réussi pendant 20 mois depuis 12
ans à à maintenir l'unité dans ses
partisans qui est pas toujours évident
il ya toutes sortes de faction à ce
parti là il ya toutes sortes de gens qui
mentent et pas toujours très content
bryan murray n'avait réussi à maintenir
c'est une unité là il ya eu la fusion
par la suite après un été très bon là
dessus mais là il ya des conservateurs
qui voient un peu dans toutes les
directions
il faut rassembler tout ce monde là il
faut trouver le bon chef il faut changer
l'image du parti qui était
essentiellement l'image de suivre un peu
il faut démontrer que le parti
conservateur peut rester fidèle à ses
principes sans qu'on soit obligé de
d'avoir ce discours dit viser un e tout
le temps où un bon le chef du jour l'air
de mauvaise humeur
c'est un gros défi mais il a reconnu
quand vous regardez tous les candidats
qui dont on parle en ce moment il ya des
gens intéressants biya pas de super
héros qui pointe à l'horizon il y en a
pas dans aucun des partis de façon jeu
des xviii e siècle d'abord à sion mais
c'est mémé c'est un gros défi mais comme
ryan malone et le dit et tout à l'heure
à marines au ils ont du temps ils
reprendront pas de cours pendant deux
ans ils ont tout le temps de penser à ce
qu'ils veulent de nous et ça c'est un
luxe dans un sens qu'on a un
gouvernement majoritaire pour les
intégrer et conservateurs c'est un luxe
parce que ça va leur permettre une
reconstruction pour les conservateurs je
suis d'accord il faut changer le mode de
gestion il faut changer le
la façon de faire et non seulement la
communication mais je pense la gestion
en interne du parti
oui il ya une certaine unité mais je
suis pas d'accord il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont très frustrés dans le parti et
le 2 janvier ils sont frustrés parce que
ils sentent que depuis plusieurs
factions comme les progressistes qui se
sentent aliéner le départ de monsieur
mais qui par exemple était vu comme un
abandon dans un sens de cette aile du
parti
alors il faut trouver une façon de
rassembler le fameux big tent commentée
en anglais maintenant c'est un petit
propre et on obtient alors il doit faire
cela et ce n'est pas seulement aidé dans
mes la course à la chefferie c'est
l'idéal pour le faire ils vont avoir des
candidats de partout alors celles ci
vont changer un peu la dn2 du parti
conservateur que ceux comme il est
maintenant est ce que là on a vu que la
base réformer c'est encore extrêmement
solides les résultats du parti le
demande sa base traditionnelle est là
mais est-ce qu'il va avoir quelqu'un qui
vont essayer de ramener deux parties un
peu vers le centre est est ce que ça
pourrait être possible
moi j'en suis pas certain et c'est
intéressant de voir aussi il reste le
seul endroit au canada où les
conservateurs ont fait des gains au
québec
est-ce que c'est elle québécoise eve
avoir de l'influencé ce que ces gens là
de maxime bernier a au maire de
victoriaville monsieur reyes sont
capables d'apporter à ce parti s'il a
une pensée nouvelle pensée plus libérale
avec le petit elle ils peuvent jouer en
route recette intégrale
il nous reste très peu de temps mais sur
le npd alors là on a vu cette cuisante
défaite
et on peut dire cruel même est parti
quand même en tête
donc est ce que est ce que thomas
mulcair peut rester il reste chef
d'achat je pense qu'il va rester chef
pour le moment comme les conservateurs
se précipitent plus vers une course à la
chefferie parce que monsieur apple dit
john mais monsieur 1015 je pense va
attendre un peu
parce qu'elle pas c'est pas où tu n'y a
pas autant de gens je pense dans l'un
des 10 à beaucoup de députés comme megan
oiseaux qui ont été défaites et
candidats de qualité pour la chefferie
qui ne sont plus là alors nous permettre
je pense à plus de gens de sortir dans
le décor pour le parti et 44 sièges
écoute c'est c'est le deuxième meilleur
score qu'ils ont jamais eu dans
l'histoire 2011 survécu aux attentes
mais le parti n'est pas n'est pas
moribond grosse introspection afin parce
que si monsieur mike hayes avait perdu
suivante [ __ ] avait perdu en brandissant
l'étendard progressiste bon les gens là
dit bon on s'est fait battre son procès
mais là il donne l'impression d'avoir
sacrifié l'âme du parti et les résultats
ne sont pas là s'il avait gagné on
aurait probablement on aurait
certainement oublier ce petit recentrage
mais là il ya perdu et il ya beaucoup de
gens je pense qu'ils vont nous dire
écoutez la ricotta temps passant le npd
nous environne
une valeur de base alors ça serait
peut-être pas si facile que ça le monde
a faim le npd n'a pas cette tradition de
mettre ses chefs à la porte des très dur
avec ses chefs qu'ils ont enduré en plus
maigre argent ni alexandre eck de notes
pendant plusieurs années alors que ça
n'allait nulle part exacte de
catastrophique
sauf qu'un michel raison il ya des
joueurs importants qui ont été battus je
pense à patna actuelle je pense a pas le
droit négocié qui sont vraiment pas
content et qui vont demander des contre
le cimetière ils vont venir le disait
déjà way du courage en projet en tout
cas pas écouter ça a été quand même une
campagne vraiment intéressante élections
intéressante alors on vous donne congé
jeudi prochain 3